also uh we still got as familiar to that
whole backlash thing with him choking
that lady is no no tears everyone just
cares about Batman like his name has
popped up a few times in videos since
that happened and I'm like we're not
gonna dress this right on unless he did
blackface ten years ago nothing that's
the new offense and there's only one at
a time
hello there reject nation we're gonna
watch today from Charlie's emergency
awesome the Batman
20:21 and Michael Kate on Justice League
crossover movies breakdown and we'll
talk about what he covers in this video
afterwards just wanted to say it's
summer break right now so you might hear
some kids who are not practicing social
distancing outside cuz it's a lovely
community here very close quarters very
tight yet he never shut up they never
shut up it sounds like they've got a few
animals down there as well oh my god I
really hope we can hear them what do you
think about this jennamarbles situation
oh and I've topical let's do this
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Batman video there
are a lot of questions based on the
Michael Keaton news in coming back is
Batman I just finished Gotham all the
videos all you have to do to enter is be
subscriber and let me know which other
movies you want Michael Keaton's Batman
to cross them definitely that one right
he's gonna be one I'm in a face for
[Laughter]
trilogy justice my future Justice League
crossover movies and then future Batman
spin-off movies with other characters
like a live-action Batman Beyond movie
the future is Japanese as far as I can
see it's just like Batman
that's all we can rely on
[Music]
normally the TV shows the copy but the
movies are doing but come movies and
superhero movies have evolved to the
point where fans understand respective a
1/4 tree twist the comics have been
trading on for 40 or 50 years it's all
about the multiverse Marvel is taking
its movies in the MCU in the exact same
direction take a hard left in as a
multiverse to keep things fresh and
weird so number 4 according to The Wrap
yesterday Warner Brothers plans are that
Matt Reeves and Robert Pattinson as
Batman trilogy is still meant to be the
future of the Batman
if they're right give him a fresh start
with the new actor and the new sort of
Batman franchise
they're letting that new Batman trilogy
exist often a stone bubble of continuity
separate from Justice League Snyder cut
however you want to think about that
line of continuity this started with the
Man of Steel movie what a Matt Reeves
previous statements was something like
yes the movie is part of the DC comic
book universe kind of guys should read
that comic if you have a brand under DC
Comics but in reality it's not meant to
be connected to other movies they're not
going to be referencing Superman
during the Batman movie next year
they're not gonna be referencing the
Justice League or anything like that so
just be talking about the Batman
characters inside Gotham City there's
you lose the opportunity for them to
change their minds about that in the
future but it's not meant to start out
that way and here's where we get to the
multiverse where it all starts to make a
little more sense number three Michael
Keaton is coming back in early next year
[Music]
Michael Keaton does appear in
[Music]
West Batman series Robin hideous sure
gorilla word Robin
the crisis is now
from different movies and TV shows there
was a lot of fun the idea and I have
until you actually see someone from the
Christopher Nolan movies interact with
someone from the DC EU movies the flash
flashpoint movie with Michael Keaton's
1989 Batman will be the first official
time they do something to us but they
say that every single DC movie is going
to be connected now inside the DC etu
I'm sure there will be a lot of other
funny multiverse references hopefully
John Wesley Shipp gets a cameo seat
hopefully Kevin Conroy at some point
we'll get a cameo scene in one of the
live-action DC movies the version of
Flashpoint that they're going to be
doing for the flash movies gonna be very
different from the comic book version
Ezra Miller has spent more time talking
about the movie in the context of
broadening the multiverse then talking
about the actual flashpoint comic book
story multiverse stories are very common
for the flash they've been doing the
multiverse with alternate versions of
the characters on the flash TV show for
several years now so even if you haven't
watched that TV show in a while you
totally know what's going on why they're
bringing back right now instead of using
Robert Pattinson's Batman in the flash
flashpoint movie for big crossover is
because of what I said before they want
to protect Matt Reeves from having to
overcomplicate his Batman movie stories
with the idea of the multiverse but DC
needs a Batman in its bigg Justice
League crossovers Batman is just too big
of an IP to leave him out of these big
Justice League movies in the DC EU Ben
Affleck has already said that he's done
in the movies the whole reason why he
said he as much of a bummer is that is
he's coming back to do additional
voiceover dialogue for the Justice
League Snyder cut but right now that's
it and technically that's not a new
movie that's an old movie the Zack
Snyder never got to finish making it now
he's just finishing it so is the rap
deadline variety all the other trade
publications per saying yesterday Warner
Brothers solution for having their
crossover Batman in the future DC EU
movies is just to do the older style
Batman with Michael Keaton in an it fury
type of role someone to cameo in
crossover and multiple movies helping
tie everything together leading up to
another big team out Justice League
sequel down the road and because it has
to be more of a specific reason why
though Batman will still be canon but
because memories won't be done with his
Batman trilogy for at least seven or
eight years however long it takes them
to make three new Batman movies and
Warner Brothers will probably want to do
their next Justice League movie
for that happens and they don't want to
cross over with Robert Pattinson's
Batman franchise during that trilogy
Michael Keaton's Batman from Earth's 89
is just a solution to that problem you
need a Batman in that next Justice
League movie but you don't want to touch
Robert Pattinson while they're finishing
that trilogy because the Baffler Michael
he's a giant pile of cash to come back
and even though I haven't mentioned it
yet Michael Keaton is actually doing the
exact same thing with his vulture
character in the sinister six team-up
that they're not Joe Marvel movies in
the Sony spider-man movies so this is
the first time the Michael Keaton has
done this he's actually gonna be in the
Morbius movie asses vulture character
from spider-man homecoming next year so
it'll give you a good idea for what it's
gonna be like seeing his Batman pop up
in a bunch of different DC movies but
since Warner Brothers is still saying
that Robert Pattinson's Batman is the
main Batman I think that just implies
that when Michael Keaton does show up as
Batman inside other DC movies though
mostly do smaller cameo scenes when we
made the Nick Fury comparison think
about it this way there were only been
three Marvel movies really where Nick
Fury was in most of the movie most of
the time he just shows up for a couple
scenes then goes away and I'm also kind
of expecting that when Michael Keaton's
Batman it does show up on screen with
the other DC characters most of the time
he will not be wearing a Batman costume
they'll just look like old Bruce Wayne
from Batman Beyond so number one
obviously live-action Batman Beyond is
the other thing the Internet has been
talking about holy to watch in the
thought a minute a new Justice League
movie sounds amazing but I still think
that Warner Brothers ultimate plan is to
develop another new Batman franchise
after Matt Reeves movies with Batman
Beyond Sony is doing the exact same
thing now with their spider-man movies
it has the main MCU spider-man movies
with Tom Hall and Peter Parker but it's
also doing the spider-man into the
spider burst movies with alternate
versions of Peter Parker and other
spider-man it has also doing the venom
movies with Tom Hardy former Batman
movie villain so why they see Warner
Brothers wants to get to the point where
capitalise on other Batman characters in
the movies Batman Beyond is just one of
the biggest most popular characters that
they've never tried in any of the big of
laibach I know why not take on the
character my always open that is if they
do wind up doing Batman Beyond in the
movies but they'll let Kevin Conroy
cameo at some point Terry McGinnis Wayne
everything click here for my other
brand-new Michael Keaton Batman video
and click here to word about the new
version of the Joker that they're
supposedly introducing during the new
Batman trilogy thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe well we've
already covered a good amount of support
but I guess the newest sort of
perspective of anticipation the fact of
the multiverse crossovers yeah crisis on
Infinite Earths which was it was really
fun I had a lot of fun watching that
they did have a lot of these like super
duper to quit cameos a wide variety of
appearances they did tie in the burden
Batman to that there was some like
newspaper photo or something of Michael
Keaton and I think it was he's married
to Selina Kyle in there but you focus on
the reporter Alexander Knox at one point
that's tied in but it's making me wonder
like how will they use flashpoint as a
way to really tie everything in because
cress and Infinite Earths successfully
managed to do a whole bunch of tying in
movies and shows and even bran and Ralph
plays Adam on legends of tomorrow and
then was able to return as Superman as
well on there which was a whole lot of
fun you know there's also the Nolan
Batman movies which haven't been tied in
it it's always been kind of cool that
it's really its own thing like truly is
its own thing Charlie in this video is
talking a lot about how they don't want
to worry about that with the Matt Reeves
Robert Pattinson Batman films but if
it's still under the DC extended
universe umbrella I feel like they're
going to want to tie it in against
aren't they I'm not opposed to that I
don't see why that would be problematic
see for like a first movie really making
it do its own thing but eventually
crossing over Robert Pattinson Xin to
the Justice League would be cool I just
wonder if it would be confusing for
people especially with the way we have
grown accustomed to mashups to team ups
that if that Batman franchise is
supposed to be the main Batman franchise
and then whenever they do another
Justice League movie wouldn't you be
expecting Robert Pattinson's Batman to
be the one that goes into that movie yes
yeah I have right now and I feel like
flashpoint could easily straighten a lot
of that out but it does seem like they
are in a weird problematic place where
they have this very solid future of a
Batman trilogy planned and then they
also have whatever the current
continuity is which is apparently
especially if like the Suicide Squad is
in the indicator it feels like they have
a very fractured continuity at this
point where they're just gonna keep what
worked and replace what maybe didn't
work and so I wish that the patents and
stuff like the Nolan's stuff could just
be its own isolated universe because
partly as excited as I am about
multiverses and stuff I also do like
when some of these stories get to just
have their own focus but yeah that
that's the biggest question to me is if
Robert Pattinson isn't supposed to be
you know tied up into all the rest of
the universe are we then gonna get a
Justice League movie where it's Michael
Keaton and Batman doesn't really fight
that yeah that would it be satisfactory
yeah exactly gonna want to see Batman
you can ask unless they bring in Batman
Beyond before that new Justice League
and make him the ass-kicking Batman see
what this the thing that raised a
question for me now though is they see
that you know this Snyder cut business
was a good idea they're already noticing
that you know with their multiverse
shenanigans they got going on they could
find a way to make the Snyder cut
depending on how well that's received
and how financially successful that is
make that more of the Canon because
right now the word is it's not it's just
its own thing yeah everything seems like
it could be in this weird gray area
what is really its own thing yes any of
this really it's something the only more
thing I'm convinced is its own thing is
that Joaquin Phoenix Joker yeah yeah and
even then it could still not be forever
its own thing yeah it just right now
that's the only one murder I firmly
believe yeah they don't have any plans
to tie this into anything you know just
wouldn't work it wouldn't work but the
Snyder cut with multiverses it mean
maybe they could still have the one that
we didn't took over be the cannon of it
then you know under than another
alternate dimension whatever the Snyder
cut plate happen you know it could be
doing that as well I mean everything
with like the talk with Michael Keaton I
don't I guess I don't really read into
it that much I thought are just gonna be
a fun multiverse crossover because I saw
crisis on Infinite Earths you know
result is hype with what they were doing
and the main thing that they did was
they tied everything together not
everything but a lot of the properties
together write down a small bill and
even then that Smallville moment was
just a thing for Smallville fans yeah
that didn't really contribute to the
tale of it they tied in the DC EU
directly the the current movies by
having Ezra Miller's flash appear and
that was a really great very fun scene
and that was like the first time as her
Miller's flash is learning like he's
learning about the multiverses and stuff
you know I guess it's just like which
Batman are we gonna end up with in the
next Justice League movie yeah and
because like this whole thing with
Michael Keaton being the Nick Fury is
like that's the terminology they've been
throwing around I can't wrap my head
around why that's essential or why we
need the Tim Burton Batman to be the one
to do it it's like I don't you feel like
you can't just do one movie yeah I mean
the thing is it makes the most sense to
me obviously to do some kind of Batman
Beyond or or at least if he is to appear
as a Nick Fury type character I feel
like a Batman Beyond is the proper
circuit to make that work because
otherwise it does feel like well we have
multiverse options now so who can we get
oh what about Michael Keaton let's go
all the way back nostalgia I felt like
they were just doing what they did on
crisis on Infinite Earths it's like I'm
sure some of that multiverse bending
factor and very importantly to you know
Cannon down the road and to the
immediate plot at hand for Barry Allen
in that film Michael Keaton I had the
thing that would excite me the most is a
Batman Beyond movie that's the one you
got it to with Timothy shell yeah
Terry kid but that's the thing is that
sets you up I guess that's the thing for
me is is that prospect is exciting cuz
then I'm gonna go oh that we're gonna
see Bruce Wayne as an old man he's gonna
get to be a character whereas if he's
Nick Fury it's like Charlie pointed out
he should gonna show up a few times you
know like get him out he briefed and I
don't expect the lion's share of
impactful and memorable character
moments would go to him and that's
something that especially like I get it
on the one hand because if you're gonna
have any of the Batman actors return
Adam West's past Michael Keaton makes
the most sense to me because I think he
is the most blanket beloved like
definitive Batman casting that you could
bring back and have everyone be that
excited about I just don't want this to
be a thing where it's like well we can
do it why not well yeah I think it has
to do with a flip at the crisis on
Infinite Earths already tied in Batman
89 you know Ben Affleck is kind of in
this strange Batman purchase horridly
neither cut does really really well in
his Batman's just like way different and
even better in that movie I wouldn't
ever rule out the possibility of him
coming back in some degree especially
those multiverse business yeah I just I
kind of wonder if the Michael Keaton
cameo thing it could be read into a
little too much it's like is he an
actual supporting player as these
reports are talking about or will it
just be a fun few minutes so they can
you know which I wouldn't mind like I
wouldn't I wouldn't mind that but if
you're gonna bring about Michael Keaton
as a pivotal character at Batman Beyond
the way to do it like that's the version
we should and that could be a well
justified multi like a different
universe movie to do where you got
Robert Pattinson Batman which is very
different not tied in and then he could
explore this other alternate version of
Batman in the future and then he has
this apprentice and someone else who's
not Bruce Wayne is taking on the Batman
soul and that's the closest to like they
reference spider-verse here you know
think about that like it's not Peter
Parker as
main characters Miles Morales but you
have a Peter Parker as the mentor so
likening spider-verse to what they want
to do all the crazy Batman movies that
would make the most sense that's the one
I most prefers if he comes back for that
that would just be very exciting well
that's one of those rare opportunities
you get to when you know Hollywood
you've seen him be the young Batman
years ago yeah and even in the Batman
Beyond cartoon it's like you had Kevin
Conroy still voicing Batman after the
classic run of the animated series and
so to be able to actually realize that
physically for a Batman Beyond movie
would be why tailored perfect to me yeah
and I feel like that would be a missed
opportunity not to do so because also
Batman Beyond like that's gonna get
people's interest regardless yeah yeah
and it's also on tread to live-action
territory I really hope that's what they
go for cuz the rest just doesn't seem as
perfect as that and that's an issue to
me also uh we still got as familiar that
whole backlash thing with him choking
that ladies know there's everyone just
cares about Batman like his name has
popped up a few times in videos since
that happened and I'm like we're not
gonna dress this john unless he did
blackface ten years ago nothing that's
the new offense there's only one at a
time I should have been addressed I
agree it should have been addressed
[Laughter]
well maybe Michael Keaton Noah you know
bring him and bring him room yeah maybe
they'll cross over there into that
moment that's how are you gonna Mercier
an actor an actor and you were choking
this woman now I got to teach you about
justice I know we just said ourselves
with to get cancelled by joking about
this no guys should we be canceled
subscribe with the real rejects where he
woods Batman do you want to show up into
Justice League movies no people are
still want bath like I feel like there's
a lot of love out there for bad flick I
certainly wouldn't expect any backlash
if he were to come back he's the one
agreeable part of CBS and just like I
think it's because we never got to have
closure
hmm and his Jimmy Kimmel appearance
isn't satisfactory if you've done the
appearance in the Batsuit alright guys
well we'll catch you soon thank you
emergency awesome subscribe to Charlie's
channel subscribe to us hit like buttons
and happy birthday mom it's better
birthday today
birthday